(audience applauds)
It's time for Drew's News.
We climb up the news tree
to pluck the good news coconuts. (mimics coconut clacking)
And with me at the desk is my trusty co-pilot, literally,
whether it's in an RV or at a desk, Ross Matthews.
Hi, Everybody.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Hi!
Rossy.
Yes?
Would you like to kick us off today?
I would, Drew, because can you all believe it?
But 2022 marks the 40th anniversary of "ET".
Yep.
Yeah.
(audience cheers and applauds)
So crazy.
Does it feel like 40 years ago that "ET" came out?
I mean, it does, you know, but not in a bad way.
In like a, "Ooh, these last 40 years have been jam packed".
They have.
And "ET" means so much to so many people.
I mean, everyone here, you know, everybody loves that movie.
(audience cheers and applauds)
There's one super fan who loves the movie.
His name is John Oliver,
(Drew gasps)
who were obsessed with.
And Mashable reports that John Oliver just told Jimmy Fallon
that "ET" was the very first movie he ever saw
and his parents had to physically carry him out
of the theater, 'cause he said he was screaming in tears
because he was heartbroken that, at the end, spoiler alert,
Elliot didn't go with "ET"
(audience reacts in sentiment)
which is the ending he wanted to see, right?
Yeah. Anything John Oliver wants.
I know.
Can we we redo the ending?
Well John is actually our neighbor, here at the studio
and it's fun that we're all coworkers,
'cause you actually ran into him recently, right?
Well, no, at the beginning,
when the pandemic was first starting
and we were launching in September, 2020,
I was so excited that the man, I,
one of the men I admire the most on planet Earth
would be our neighbor,
but they were shooting from a different location
'cause of COVID.
Yeah. But I think,
but didn't you run into him in the hallways here?
Well, I certainly did.
Yeah, and what happened then?
Well, um, I, I kind of yelled at him.
You kinda yelled at him.
Yeah. You...
You know me, I'm a little rebellious and naughty.
I was upset 'cause I was like, "Oh my God!
You're supposed to be my neighbor."
Yeah, yeah.
And you're in the white space
somewhere I don't even know.
Uh-huh.
Except you were wearing a hat and a mask
so he had no idea it was Drew.
Oh gosh.
(audience applauds)
I love him so much.
Well speaking of ever so exciting (sighs lustily)
Uh-huh. Oh, I know.
Bridgerton is back.
Oh Bridgerton.
But...
(audience applauds)
I know, we all love it, but...
I have some weird news to report.
Apparently, people are a little upset.
The New York Post reports that some say season two
is missing two vital ingredients,
the hot and steamy sex and Jean Rege Page.
Yes.
But what people are saying, basically,
is they miss him and the sex.
Uh-huh.
Now Rossy, have you been watching it?
What thoughts?
Yeah, of course, I started,
I had to do my research, so yeah, I started.
I'm on episode two
and I even put my little finger on my iPad, like this,
to fast forward to see if there's any naked... (mutters)
(audience giggle)
And there's not, okay.
It has lost that loving feeling.
I'm still into the storyline and the beautiful,
but nothing's giving me that "Hey, hey, hey"
like Jean Rege, R-R-Rege, Oh yes.
You know that, it's a good question,
because obviously, this is not appropriate for children,
but I would feel weird watching Bridgerton with my friends.
You would?
Yes!
Well there's a few episodes in season one that
you should be alone when you, (laughs)
you know what I'm talking about.
And it doesn't mean "that" kind of alone,
but like I don't wanna be like, "Huh, what's up?"
Like we're watching (mimics grunting)
(Ross laughing)
That is not, I don't know.
I don't even sleep in the same beds as my friends.
I'm really weird.
Oh my God, well I'm so turned on,
watching (mimics grunting)
Listen. (laughs)
(audience laughs)
Maybe this is the problem.
Now Bridgerton, you guys,
last season, you always talked about how
watching that first season of the show really lit a fire,
re-lit a fire inside of you, right?
(Drew mimics grunting noises)
The sexy scenes, yeah.
I don't think season two is gonna do it.
I do,
Oh God, he's so talented.
I have to say.
(Drew laughs)
(bright music)